ladies and gentlemen robin williams
what's your brain doing when ten
thousand people are laughing their heads
off
i'm not a tuna the human brain is you
know an
extraordinary three and a half pound
gland the moment you think you
understand it it comes out with
something else
the breaking news actor robin williams
is dead at the age of 63.
they believe that the bay area resident
committed suicide
there was a lot of media speculation
on robin williams mind before his death
money he's broker he's depressed or he's
just given up
the last movie was clear to all of us on
that set that
something was going on with robin there
was something eroding within him
i was called in to go over the coroner's
report it was the beginning
of understanding what had really gone on
my husband had unknowingly been battling
a deadly disease
lewy body dementia is devastating
illness
increases anxiety self-doubt causes
delusions that have never been present
in someone
nearly every region of his brain was
under attack he experienced himself
disintegrating
i remember him saying to me i don't know
what's going on i'm not me anymore
it really amazed me that robin could
walk or move at all
people who are incredibly brilliant can
tolerate degenerative diseases better
robin williams was a genius
he was always able to power through it
and he'd become this guy
that you knew remembered and loved
the way that he was able to battle the
inner turmoils
he was a freaking warrior it no longer
feels loyal
to be silent about it but maybe more
loyal to share
he was blessed with what his heart was
capable of
in the midst of fear he wanted to
help people be less afraid self goes
away
ego bye bye the thing that matters
are others that's what life is about